it's great to be joined today by Stephen
Schwartz who is a scientist futurist and
also award-winning author he's a
columnist for the journal Explorer
editor of the daily shorts report net
and also distinguished consulting
faculty of Saybrook University
Stephan it's so interesting to speak to
you today and have been following your
work for some time and a lot of your
work that I'm very interested in relates
to social change and the role that
individuals can play in catalyzing real
and significant social change so first
just sort of to get us into this topic
talk to us a little bit about the
changes that you've seen and
participated in personally really I
think dating back to the 1960s well I
got interested in this because when I
was a teenager back in the late 50s
early 60s I got involved with the civil
rights movement and the four times in my
life I've been involved with changing
history in a life-affirming way in the
50s and 60s it was civil rights in the
70s I was this special assistant to the
Chief of Naval Operations Elmo Zumwalt
was then CNO and we were involved with
transforming the military from an
elitist conscription organization to an
all-volunteer meritocracy the military
we have today and then in the 80s I
along with a group from Esalen Institute
we started what came to be known as
citizen diplomacy creating a
back-channel between the Soviet Union in
the United States because we were afraid
we were going to have a nuclear war and
then through all of that what I think of
is the consciousness movement and its
first cousin the environmental movement
the idea that we are more than animated
meat and that all life is interconnected
and interdependent and about 16 or no
almost 18 years ago now I began doing
really serious research
looking at how individuals and small
groups can change the arc of history in
a life-affirming way so that's where I
want to start digging in with you a
little bit I mean in the various
instances that you've observed or
participated in significant social
transformations have you identified any
common characteristics in terms of the
involvement of the individual in
catalyzing those changes yes yeah that's
a very good question in fact that was
the point I recently wrote a book called
the eight laws of change which is
basically exactly how to do this so that
there's two stages or two levels of it I
guess the first is the individual level
and then there is this social group
level at the individual level it's
really remarkably simple and it doesn't
require a lot of money or doesn't
require official position or armies or
anything like that and it's simply that
whenever you are faced with the choice
and we do thousands of them every day
you know you go into a store to buy
toothpaste or cat food or something
that's really a vote in a sense and so
what you do is I call it the quotidian
choice which just means daily or mundane
everyday you make dozens and dozens of
these choices and you consistently
choose two of the options available to
you to always choose the one that is the
most compassionate and life-affirming as
you understand it at that moment so you
know you when you go in to buy the
toothpaste you look at the toothpaste
and think is this does this company
treat its workers well is it
environmentally sensitive you make
choices that you are going to make
anyway but you always make them leaning
towards or with a bias towards that
which is compassionate and
life-affirming and when this happens
when a group of people join together and
do this then you see real cultural
change
that occurs examples of that would be
well you don't see people out of people
smoking anymore nobody passed a law
against it it occurred because thousands
and thousands of people made it an
individual daily decision when you when
you look at for instance the transition
from gay to LGBT which is not just a
transition of a different term but also
a different way of conceptualizing
gender you can see that in a very short
space of time
we went from saying gay to seeing LGBT
and now it's LGBTQ because we are going
through a cultural reappraisal of what
gender means to us as as a people or
anything so you don't pretty so then you
don't there are some who believe that
that change you just identified is a
change in language and not a change in
anything else and that thus we should
not be quote policing language however
you actually believe aside from whatever
your views are about policing language
that that linguistic change does
correlate with a societal change well of
course it doesn't mean look at the
transition that marriage equality was
unthinkable during the Clinton
administration and now today if you talk
to Millennials or or what are now called
VI gens those born after 95 to them it's
just perfectly normal another example
you used to never see um interracial
romances in movies and television now if
you look at Netflix or HBO or stars as a
series they run you see that interracial
romance is a big feature because the
culture has changed not because the the
Congress or the president made some sort
of pronouncement or passed a law but
because ordinary individuals simply made
choice the power of collective intention
is the most powerful social force on
earth so Stephen when it comes to trying
to catalyze significant societal change
starting at the individual level and you
feel that none or neither of the choices
you have are particularly good I'd like
to talk a little bit about how you might
direct people to act in those ways and
just as one example you know that
there's I think it's easy to think about
this um in terms of Elections there were
a lot of people in the recent election
who identified both Donald Trump and
Hillary Clinton of fundamentally being
part of the same sort of establishment
crony capitalist status quo that they
don't like so there were some who said
well I see one candidate is less bad
than the other thus I will vote for them
and there were people who chose to
abstain altogether with the idea that
listen these two people are so close it
doesn't matter if one slightly worse I
want to burn the entire system down to
rebuild it from the ground up your
philosophy which one of those two
approaches or some other would it
support in the context of all choices
that aren't very good well here's the
key David I don't really care about
politics except anthropologically okay I
I don't want to get lost in the various
theories or blow the Asians or polemical
you know diatribes that that did this
sort of language in the talking part
well but let's apply it let's apply it
then for some other example where none
of our choices are particularly good
okay let me finish the thought instead
what I look at is social outcomes
because that's an objectively verifiable
measure you know if you do this what
happens well if you look at the world
from that point of view where if you
create this policy this is what happens
then all of this becomes much clearer so
you can look let's just take the Hillary
Trump thing Hillary Clinton may have
been a deeply flawed candidate Donald
Trump at least from my perspective on
the on the basis of his 200 days of
performance
so far has been a disaster so in terms
of social I've come down and neither one
of them was a good choice but I mean I
was a Bernie Sanders candidate but given
if you just had that choice that that
that binary choice on the basis of
social outcome data you should have
voted for Hillary Clinton because she
may be a flawed candidate but she is a
better candidate than Donald Trump on
the basis not of political philosophy or
Benghazi or the usual nonsense yeah that
eats up all the oxygen but on the basis
of performance she has a long history of
gender equality she has a long history
of looking for universal health care she
has a long history of gender equality so
on the basis just of those three things
like to pick a dozen more she may not
have been a great candidate but compared
to Donald Trump she was the better
candidate you don't always get to make
perfect choices a lot of times the
choices available to you none of them
are really very good but if you look at
them closely and you look at the social
outcome data you will see that there's
always one that's a little bit better
than the other and that's the one you
always want to choose it's not perfect
but it's better and it's the long-term
of that that makes the difference not
not our focus today but on one just one
quick thing you said I don't believe
Hillary Clinton was in favor of
single-payer health care but that's it's
not relevant to our conversation but
just just as one note it heard go back
and look at her health care failed
health care problem or policy program
when Clinton was president and you will
see that she was building the basis for
a single-payer health care okay I will
review that when it comes to violent and
nonviolent change Steven you've pointed
out that violent or coercive change in
society seems not to stick around nearly
as long as nonviolent change can you
give us some examples of that and maybe
talk about the underlying reasons why
that
might be yes actually that was one of
the most interesting things I discovered
when I was started doing this research
you know if you if you look at change
they're basically two ways change occurs
the the one that we glorify and put
statues in the park to is some violent
change but in fact if you looked at the
research of a number of scientists and
as well as my own research and and what
I am indeed social transformations
around the world from the beginning of
the 20th century to 2014 and and of
those 200 plus I've forgotten exactly
but a little over 200 what you see is
that 75 percent of those which are
involved with violent transformation do
not succeed they do not succeed and even
when they do succeed they usually
succeed only partially and even more
interestingly they only exist for a
short while the two examples of that are
National Socialism the Nazis you know
that Nazism only lasted between well
depending on how to calculate it
10 to 20 years I mean it was horrible
world war two but it only lasted about
10 to 20 years you look at the communism
which when I was in government we were
terrified of this great monolith the
Soviet Union but in fact the Soviet
Union only lasted about a little over 70
years less than the lifetime of a single
person so these things which seemed very
monolithic and incredibly powerful and
and to be with us forever in fact when
you look at violent change what you
discover is it doesn't last very long
and the reason it doesn't is that in the
process of that violent change you
create large segments of the population
which have a real brevis because they
have suffered at the hands of the change
agents whereas if you look at change
which is cursed non-violently what if
you discover is it succeeds 70
five percent of the time it only fails
25 percent and because it is inclusive
and involves people and doesn't create
hard feelings in large segments of the
population is long enduring the United
States itself is an example of that
we've been speaking about the very
interesting work of Stephen Schwartz
who's a columnist for the journal
Explorer editor of the daily shorts
report net and also distinguished
consulting faculty of Saybrook
University
Stephen I wish we had more time it would
be a pleasure to have you back on the
program to dig into some of these topics
in more detail I really appreciate you
talking to me today
my pleasure David you have a great day